reject nation hello this has become the
daily show i am jon stewart i am very
excited about this being so often how
much you guys have loved this show we
have breaking news and frankly this
couldn't wait for the other things but
before we get into that please do like
subscribe leave comments because koi's
comic corner is largely going to be
fueled by you you're like my co-host
things you want to hear about i'm going
to dive into i've already got some ideas
of future episodes so those comments are
being perused enjoyed and very much
appreciated but today with the giant
news that broke we're going to be
talking about the rumors that are
probably true about lady gaga joining
joker 2 what that means for the other
rumors the willem dafoe rumors how that
might tie into the title itself these
rumors of it being a musical how greg
called this four months ago and most of
all what i think this is going to be
influenced by with the comic books can
you tell that greg's sitting immediately
in my left that's him giggling
i'm very excited because this to me
elevates the sequel idea of what joker 2
is going to be we're going to dive into
all of that and more after these opening
credits
and we're back i'm so excited for joker
2 now that we have this big big rumor
the combination of it being lady gaga
and potentially a musical elevates this
whole thing but let's break down what
we've seen so far we know the title of
this film is joker felix
my last name is french unfortunately i
am not as per the pronunciation that
millions of french people just suffered
through i'm so sorry france foley aju
means the madness of two so many of us
had assumed that meant the willem dafoe
rumors were in fact true during the no
way home press tour willem dafoe was
very very open about the fact that yes
he knows he looks like the joker and yes
he knows we have all been fan casting
him for quite some time so much so he
had it as part of his snl opening
monologue that to me was locking in the
fact we were getting willem dafoe
opposite joaquin phoenix because
basically the plot of the first joker
movie the the moral foundation it stood
on was what is society what is culture
what does it mean when we live in a
world of nihilism where that might be
the answer how does anarchy really
differ from a lot of the choices we make
when we ignore others in society whether
you love or hate the joker movie it has
a lot to say and i really think the
joker character has a lot to say so in
that same vein willem dafoe was
seemingly going to be playing a
character that followed in the footsteps
of the joker he followed the lead of the
joker just as the third act of the film
seemed to represent they could have even
had willem dafoe photoshopped into that
last bit they could have easily started
the film with you know one of the guys
that's in that mob being william defoe
it seemed like a really cut and dry way
to do a sequel and it seemed like an
incredible idea all that being said this
might be an even better idea because it
seemingly came out of nowhere except
greg four months ago he's gonna put a
link there he's gonna take the credit he
deserves it four months ago greg said
hey there's some lady gaga rumors what
if she's harley quinn but we're hearing
these rumors about lady gaga when we're
looking at who lady gaga might be i'm
not opposed to the idea of her actually
being harlene quinzel in arkham asylum
with this madness of two it looks to be
a love story now that we have lady gaga
i no longer believe we're getting the
willem dafoe movie or it's in
conjunction with this but in a smaller
way it'd be cool to see the idea of the
commentary of another joker as maybe a
stepping stone maybe you do that
beautiful thing where you've got like a
minor villain leading up to the full
story maybe you include that idea or you
play around with the idea of willem
dafoe as someone who's trying to take
credit for some of the things that
joaquin has done either way i think if
they do involve willem it won't be the
main crux of the film anymore i think
this love story between harley and joker
is the exact right way to go with a
sequel about reality and perception
remember the first joker movie had a lot
of questions about how much of that was
in his head how much of that was in the
asylum what better type of story to tell
than one about love what clouds our
minds more than the psychology of love
what makes us think we're feeling and
seeing and experiencing things more than
love he's already in the asylum he meets
harley quinn she's his therapist we can
live in a sequel that's full david
lynchian that's got shades of fincher
that plays with all of those tropes in
the same way that the first one played
in the world of scorsese i honestly
think when the first one had those
scorsese parallels this next one is
gonna go lynch and fincher i think it's
gonna be a question of what reality is i
think it's gonna be a question of what
love makes us do i think it's gonna be a
question of how much is from the
perception of joker and how much is it
the versions of reality he's telling
harley quinn and how long into the story
do we start to see it from harley
quinn's world view i could easily see
this being a story of harleen quinzel
going into harley quinn easily this
being a story of harleen quinzel giving
us a subjective or uh objective view of
the world that then becomes subjective
once she's harley quinn i think we're
gonna see a reality distortion through
the journey of this and that's when the
musical takes off i think we're gonna be
in an augmented reality through all
these songs and you cast lady gaga
you've got someone who is a powerhouse
actress who happens to be one of the
great singers of our time someone who is
so good in that bradley cooper joint she
was up for an oscar and hadn't even
acted that much i honestly think this
could be the thing that elevates this
beyond the first movie's billion dollar
budget i personally thought you
shouldn't make a sequel to the first
joke i thought it was a beautiful else
world that had a young bruce wayne
keeping it from tying in to the batman
mythology i thought it was very smart
that they consciously showed wayne manor
they consciously had thomas wayne as a
bit of a prick because you could easily
have this be like oh he's going to fight
robert pens and batman no that would
like basically devalue both properties
instead you draw hardline in the sand
you make sure it stays in elseworld but
i thought they could leave it alone i
thought that was kind of the best way to
have that because then dc can start
doing batman by gaslight it can start
doing earth 2 superman it can start
doing these alternate realities and a
sequel kind of makes it seem like we've
got this whole other universe they're
going to live in but this this gives you
the opportunity to have the else world
feels like it's growing organically
you've got the unreality of the musical
you've got the elevation of a sequel
you've got the inherent need to make
something bigger is undermined by not
making it flashier in the cheesy sense
in the action spectacle but literally
flashy in that it's a musical this is
such an inspired move and it gives us a
harley quinn we've never seen before
we've got margot robbie as dc's main
harley quinn she is incredible she is
just as good as kelly cuoco on the dc
animated harley quinn which for my money
is maybe one of the best things dc's
ever done if you haven't seen the harley
quinn show on hbo max it is truly one of
the best adaptations without being too
serious of a translation from the comic
books what harley quinn on hbo max does
is it captures the feeling of the
characters in batman from the
perspective of harley quinn batman is
kind of a dick and he's a little horny
it's a weird character it's not our
batman i think the smart play is to do
the same thing with todd phillips's
joker 2 and have it from the perspective
of harley quinn again and that keeps you
from blending too much in the margot
robbie world that keeps you from
blending too much into the batman world
and you've got a fresh new perspective
on what she sees joaquin's successes as
or not we still to this day after
watching joker don't know how much of
that was real how cool is it gonna be to
have a new perspective on how much of
that was real by way of her in a room
talking to joker one of the most iconic
scenes in the dark knight is the
interrogation scene give me that again
but with harley quinn and have that
break into song so we're not sure how
real that is and that's going to give us
a margot robbie harley that can keep
going on in the dc eu that can grow out
to birds of prey too keep going out and
having those tie into the now more loose
shared universe of dc which i honestly
think is one of their strengths and then
very intentionally having a much more
harleen quinzell therapist psychiatrist
i'm not sure which one she is they
change it a lot they're very different
jobs but the comic books don't pick one
she could either be a psychiatrist a
psychologist or a therapist we're not
sure but i want to see that character
leaning into that side of things she
usually uses her medical background as
kind of a punch line in the in the
current margot robbie universe i want
that to be a structure a foundation of
this character here you give me a love
story with joker and harley that's
something we haven't actually seen
before there's plenty of fanfics there's
plenty of shots in the jared leto
swimming around a lot of people made
some very sensationalized youtube cuts
from the david air footage we saw we
haven't actually gotten to live in there
we've mainly seen her as a figure of
trauma that suffered through the joker
let's see them fall in love let's see
that love cloud both of their judgments
it's not a normal thing to fall so deep
in stockholm syndrome you start wearing
makeup i want to see that story we
haven't really seen it since batman the
animated series where she was invented
harley quinn is one of the few
characters that actually started outside
of the medium of comic books she was
invented in animated series and was so
popular she translated into the comics
she went the other way and now she's in
movies and i think that's a really
beautiful thing to do with joker 2. this
is a really special joke now before i
move into the comic book recommendations
what do you guys think about lady gaga
being harley quinn slash harley quinzell
what do you think about being a musical
and what do you think are going to be
the influences on this film since i do
think it's going to consciously be
separate from the scorsese joint the
first let me know in the comments i
really want to know how you guys think
this casting choice and this tone choice
will affect joker 2. but before i leave
you comic book recommendations my
favorite part of the show because i want
to get you reading the comics that i
love so so very much i would highly
recommend there's a comic book from
grant morrison one of my favorite
writers of all time called arkham asylum
serious house on a serious earth it is
an insane book with some of the most
beautiful imagery from mckean that is
super surrealistic and super visceral in
the way it makes you experience trauma
and insanity and what reality is and i
think that's gonna be a giant influence
on this movie and there's an influence
here in the writing i think is gonna tie
into joaquin's portrayal and that's the
idea of super sanity he introduces an
idea that the joker is not insane he's
so sane that he's aware of his own
identity his own physical existence as
being laughable to the point where it
almost acknowledges the level of him
being in a comic book it's not deadpool
it's not a fourth wall break in the haha
sense it's a i'm so aware of things i'm
so sane everyone else is insane around
me and they strongly hint at him knowing
he's in a fictional world by way of him
being so aware and so intelligent and so
sane this is all madness i could easily
see super sanity being something that
ties into joaquin's joker and i think
they honestly hinted at it in the first
film already i think that's going to be
the biggest basis on this story for
joker 2. so check out graham morrison's
arkham asylum a serious house on a
serious earth i would also recommend for
a more fun joke or tale there's a great
run called war of jokes and riddles it
is basically joker v riddler and it's
showing the differences in those
characters and the whole story is
basically riddler is trying to get joker
to laugh joker's forgotten how to laugh
he's lost to joy ridler is trying to get
the laugh out of the joker i could see
that being used for harley i could see
harley trying to get his approval trying
to seek his attention trying to get him
to love her by way of making him laugh i
think that's a very loose tie into the
comic book but i think that main plot
point could be utilized it's also just a
bitchin books from tom king one of my
favorite batman writers check out war of
jokes and riddles last two i recommend
for you lovelies brian azarello's joker
run brian azzarello made a trade
paperback maxi series it's not in comics
it's it's a book by itself you won't
find floppies of it it's one book just
called joker and it's some of the most
stunning imagery of the joker it looks a
lot like that heath ledger joker but
it's nauseating to look at it's very
grotesque it's almost a horrible and it
leans into the joker as his own
character he's not fighting batman he's
not doing his own thing and it's how he
perceives the world so the reason the
book feels so graphic is you're looking
at it from joker's worldview and that's
a really important distinction for the
character and i'd also recommend the
current run of harley quinn where she is
just basically trying to be good she's
trying to absolve herself from the
things that joker made her do and i
don't necessarily think we'll get to
that point in the character but a lot of
times the comic books do allow a certain
flavor to be interpreted into the movies
themselves so you might get an idea of
which harley quinn which taken the
character they might be going with plus
the animation's fun it's got a very ties
in the hbo max series a good amount with
the style of art and things so death in
the family also badass but i'm gonna
talk about that in another show another
episode down the line but it's very
essential for the joker and they might
reference some robin stuff in this one
just like they reference batman in the
first that's gonna do it daily episodes
koi's comic corner every time news
breaks we'll be filming these from
boston to my phone i feel like it's
gonna happen thank you for being here
leave a like leave a comment subscribe
hit that bell again if there's anything
you want me to talk about leave a
comment below i'm reading all of them
just don't be a dick thanks
[Music]